i have to say i'm impressed with your
backdrop
thank you it's absolutely gorgeous very
smart i'm very smart
[Laughter]
your background says i'm very smart my
background says i have no friends
yes it does actually no this is um it's
a
abandoned theater largo in uh in west
hollywood but
yeah largo's a very special place uh
although it's it has an odor
right now um it might be left over from
me i don't know
you know i walked in and i'm like it's
kind of seagully it's kind of got a
seagull stench uh where
where are you by the way i can see that
you're in a some kind of public library
in a very well-to-do school but where
are you exactly
yes uh well right now right now i'm at
my house
um i live i live like a couple hours
outside of los angeles some low-low farm
town
oh nice do you like do you like uh i
mean
small town living is it is it boring is
it okay
it's boring in a really great way uh i
really liked
i i don't know i'm i had grown up in la
i had never left and then i moved
to this little town and pretty instantly
like right when i arrived
i went to the grocery store and a man
sized me up as
an outsider and he was like welcome to
town
don't be an [ __ ] wow
okay he said because that would make you
the town
[ __ ] i thought i like this place i
wish someone had told me that when i
came to l.a
i didn't know i just
the nice thing about being an [ __ ] i
have found in la is i blend
right in uh no
i i really like i really like knowing my
neighbors and
it's a really nice feeling i like it a
lot yeah
also though you do have to i've always
heard that people in small towns
like people like john mellencamp were
always singing the praises of small
towns
but the truth is everyone gossips about
everybody else
so you you have to you've got to make
sure
that you stay on the straight and narrow
and that nobody knows your business
you have to just do nothing you have to
do
absolutely nothing you know i'll tell
you a story that i've never told before
actually
okay i popped up some cabins i live in
an orchard and i popped up some cabins
for if guests come to visit
yeah and uh one of the guys who was
popping up the cabins
made some off-handed joke he was like
what are you
uh you're starting a nudist colony and i
kind of laughed it off
i was like yeah and then
like a year later i was at a restaurant
and the waitress was like okay you have
to answer because we're all
taking bets back there is it true you
moved here to open a nudist colony
so that was that was the rumor that
spread around that i was the big nudist
i did something a little like that once
i was in a restaurant and it was after
hours and they were sort of closing the
place down and everybody was like
laughing in a good mood and i said as a
complete joke
um the the waiter was like saying
anything else
and i said cocaine for everyone you know
like whatever
and everybody laughed and the waiter
left and then i sort of got a year later
i went back to the restaurant they're
like well we were here the time you were
demanding cocaine and i'm like
i said and i said i've never done
cocaine in my life
i am the squarest i don't do drugs i was
kidding and they were like
whatever whatever yeah i just can't
convince them once it's out there
i tried to express like you know i've
shown my body in several movies
the chances of me like being a nudist
are pretty minimal i'd have a better
body by now